Sleep is critical.
Yeah.
It's um,
you know what it is is amazing for sleep,
man.
You know we should get in your place.
Get yourself a sauna.
Really?
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
He'd do 20 call shall sign of.
That's for fucking clowns.
You wear a rubber nose when you do it.
Yeah.
Hey man,
I told showers after yoga.
You bear our rubber nose.
He fuck man.
Just being mean to me.
Clowns a fucking clown.
Fucking clown and trying to quake shock proteins.
Yeah.
I've got to get really cold.
You shove an ice bath.
You want to do that?
I'll do an ice bath.
I've done that.
Done Cryo.
Yeah.
Don't cry.
Have you done the real one when you had those in now than you did the one where
the neck below on?
It has the bullshit one.
Really?
Yeah.
The real ones only made by cryo healthcare.
They have one in New York or one center in New York.
They have one in La.
They have one here.
They wanted woodland hills like 10 minutes.
A Nice path for 20 minutes and talk to me.
Um,
okay.
You go numb.
It sucks.
I'm sure,
but so does 250 degrees below zero.
If you're not,
then eyes for three minutes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Come on Bro.
It sucks.
All right bro.
I get it.
You were fucking [inaudible].
I slouch,
slouching knows I just doubled,
burned him knowing a song I was singing.
Same.
Awesome.
Um,
yeah,
it's not good.
Um,
there's probably some real benefits to ice baths.
The benefit of um,
cryo over ice baths.
You could work out right afterwards.
Ice Baths,
they recommend you not work out there.
Like you just chill out for awhile.
But it's great after working out.
But for muscles,
strength and development,
it's actually not good to do it right after training.
You actually should wait quite a while,
like maybe an hour or two.
So when you,
you've been,
you've had countless conversations with cutting edge scientists and exercise
people.
The five things that you do every day,
like that debt without fail,
what are they in terms of for your health?
First of all,
I supplement,
I think you believe in south,
I believe absolutely whole heartedly and supplements like,
which though,
what kind Tom?
I take athletic Greens.
It's a,
it's a sponsor.
Um,
they have,
it's a great whole food supplement.
I'm doing an ad for him right now.
One,
one serving as 12 one scoop has 12 servings of fruits and vegetables in terms of
the amount of antioxidants and yet very healthy.
It's good just for like a backup plan.
Right.
I take these little packs with being on the road.
Um,
I take a lot of the Onnit Shit I take,
uh,
obviously I shouldn't dash shroom tech,
you know,
we have some awesome whole food supplements.
There's a bunch of great stuff.
Um,
I take a lot of vitamins.
I take vitamin D,
I take vitamin B,
I take a lot of fish oil,
a lot of essential fatty acids.
I believe in all those things.
All right.
Cut Way back on my sugar.
I mean,
way back.
Yeah.
To where maybe once a week I'll have dessert.
Yeah,
I do that too.
Yeah.
I don't fuck around,
man.
Yeah.
Um,
I just intermittent fast.
Yes.
16 hours a day.
Yeah,
I do that too.
That makes me feel that,
you know,
my psoriasis is 100% gone.
That's awesome.
Part of it's also,
and I got to give a shout out to Dan Garner.
Dan Garner 88 at Gmail if you need his email.
He's a fuck.
So he's the guy who was a terrible idea.
No,
no,
it's fine.
It's fine.
I want to,
I want to promote them because he really fucking,
people are going to email them,
put pictures of Dicks.
Good.
But there are a lot of people have psoriasis.